there is no stopping learning you talked
about being a lifelong learner we keep
Pace you have to expose yourself to new
ideas
upskilling is a bit of a intimidating
term for some so I think of myself as a
lifelong learner simply learn fit my
learning style one
and then two the actual program itself
gave me the skills I was looking for it
wasn't surface level I was actively
every week coding in R coding in Python
education isn't a
doesn't have an end date hey John
welcome to this platform today
um you know John I know that you're a
very senior person at Walmart you are
the vice president of global finance and
Innovation and you know I I run the
product organization here so I know what
a large responsibility it is to be the
person responsible for Innovation and
Financial
um so I'm really looking forward to
learning a lot from you today and
understanding your journey uh I
understand that you've been on the
simple platform a lot to hear more about
the housing wise and what's of that but
with that said love to hear a little bit
about you and your role at broadmart I
know I've given a nice title but love to
hear what's behind the title what do you
do
sure so I'm responsible for global
technology so all of the systems all of
the technical processes and
infrastructure related to our finance
function and finance within Walmart is
changing so we are not traditional
Finance we are actually end-to-end total
organizational and operational
experience so when you think of any
decision that's made within a
corporation generally financials are
part of that key decision metric and
that's what we're responsible for
providing reliable information that
ultimately leads to better decisioning
and and obviously we have the regulatory
management and decision science
components of that as well as a very
large data program that we're
responsible for
other than John you know I've always
wondered
frankly data wasn't there 10 years back
and the data is like a big rage and Ai
and everything is taking over right uh
for someone like you and your
organization for that matter right just
being on top of the latest trends
Technologies
um that's quite a challenge at least
from where I sit right you know give us
a little bit of an insight into some of
the challenges that you're running today
on a daily basis maybe quarterly basis
or yearly basis in just keeping on top
of technology and being aware of what's
going on uh what are some of the
challenges you have right now and you
know what are some of the things you've
done and what your ARG has done to solve
these kind of problems
well one of our largest goals at Walmart
and Global Tech is really to develop our
talent
when you think of the challenges that
any large corporation might face where
you have disparate data elements that
you're trying to pull together to gain
insights that work is not
easy you are trying to rationalize plans
and then mature that data to a point
where the lineage is clearly understood
that you can trace that lineage all the
way back to the source of record and
that you can expose that data for useful
insights to make Better Business
decisions and one of the biggest
challenges that we have is we're the
number one retailer in the world and we
have lots of data so our goal is really
to expose that data in meaningful ways
so that we can help people live better
through better pricing and also with
Better Mix we can provide better
solutions for our customers and as you
are using this data to personalize in
some sense the outcome for your
customers right you know the algorithms
and the and the Technologies changing
behind you all the time right
um you know what are some of the things
that you and your team have done to keep
up with some of these Trends and
Technologies behind you
well I think it's all about leading from
the front so myself when when we look at
what's needed predictive outcomes are
one of the components to a successful
deployment these days
so understanding what it takes to go
from
more of a legacy historical reporting
perspective to something that can gain
you can gain insights from before the
activity even happens
that's really where we're headed as is
really an industry so to keep Pace you
have to expose yourself to new ideas you
really have to push yourself to learn
and that's what this Journey's been all
about for me it's a personal Learning
Journey to not only keep Pace with where
the Market's going but actually keep
Pace with my associates you have to have
the information in order to lead well
and that's part of my personal Journey
keeping up with your Associates which is
a very humble thing to say but very true
thing to say as well
that's right which leads to the question
you know upscaling rescaling big deal uh
you did come to Simply learn you took
one of our programs on data science and
and you completed it and amazing which
is a great achievement considering how
rigorous that intense it is
um so I got a very simple question
when you were thinking about taking a
program and a course and you you were
thinking well look I need to learn
something here what was it that you were
trying to achieve and once you you know
walk me through it through it right why
did you pick simple learn because I know
there are so many other great programs
out there that can give you something or
the other right love to hear the why and
then you know why simply learn sure uh
when I was looking at what the next step
for me would be in in knowledge
acquisition
tough Skilling is a bit of a
intimidating term for some so I think of
myself as a lifelong learner I'm always
looking for opportunities to learn from
others and that can be in an informal
communication where you're just learning
about a new technology or a thought
process
peers across markets have always been
something that I've leaned heavily on
based on on my experience
the reason why I chose data science is
really that is where our industry's
expectations heading and like I said
Walmart is all about developing talent
and I wanted to showcase
not only that that is one of our core
beliefs but supporting our Associates
through those Journeys is another piece
so
the reason why I chose data science at a
practical level is that we were making a
lot of decisions around how we would
implement
various programs I have no fewer than
five major programs going on right now
all of which have a data science
component to try to help our business
make better decisions and I found that
if I could gain that skill if I could
learn python in R if I could go through
a rigorous program such as simply learn
that I would have the foundational
information I needed to make better
decisions as a leader we why simply
learned question it's actually quite
simple one is I had the ability to go
through a structured program which I
appreciate
to have instructor-led courses
where I could actively ask questions
I could gain a better understanding
through those questions live questions
and then turn around in in my
assignments each week I can gain further
understanding through practice so I'm an
experiential learner but I am also an
interactive learner and knowing your
learning style is extremely important to
being successful in these programs
simply learn fit my learning style one
and then two the actual program itself
gave me the skills I was looking for it
wasn't surface level I was actively
every week coding in R coding in Python
troubleshooting why my correlations with
match my expectation
digging through those results to try to
make it better on my own even though the
coursework was over I was so entrenched
in this masked data or fake data that I
was still trying to figure out how to
make it better but I found myself
applying those weekly learnings to my
daily work which was which was an
exciting outcome as I was going through
the course
the connection with Purdue was also
extremely important to me I wanted to
make sure that when this was done that
it was an industry acknowledged
program and that there was some weight
behind exactly what the certification or
the postgraduate degree was all about
and having Purdue's name behind that
structure really helps me make that
decision just maybe summarize what I
heard from you I think your learning
stuff like the boot camp style of how we
deliver it which is the instructor-led
and practice oriented and then you get a
very credible certificate again that's
the Curiosity were there any areas of
the program that you felt really stood
out as something that you said wow that
is amazing I really enjoyed this part
any topics or features that you thought
were sort of very exciting and something
that you took away
one of the components in the uh in the
learning platform that I found very
interesting and actually leveraged quite
a bit
was the fact that I didn't have to have
the software downloaded on my machine
I could actually use the interactive
platforms that were there available for
me to go in and do my coding to save it
to come back to it later it was there
for a period of time
um and it really allowed me to execute
my assignments from anywhere and that
freedom allowed me to go on a few family
trips with my uh my family I would work
from the hotel
for a few hours on a Saturday or Sunday
just to stay current with the coursework
but it did provide that freedom to where
I didn't have to worry about how many
computers I was carrying with me Etc
wonderful it looks like the virtual Labs
were very helpful in your journey
um
yeah that's what we're going through
this program John
um you know there was a there it
probably was really rigorous but you did
complete it once you completed it now
that you're done of course great relief
I'm sure but how do you think the the
learning side of the course are going to
be applied in your day-to-day work how
do you connect your learnings to what
you're doing you know you talked about
the problems you're trying to solve how
does that connect together
but two things one I education isn't a
doesn't have an end date in in what
simply learn in the program provided for
me
was the opportunity to have a base level
understanding of data science and a few
in a few developmental languages that
most frequently are used for that
activity right for to execute data
science
um
I apply it daily in my conversations
with the data scientists that work on my
teams
I apply it daily with
measuring the goals of our top programs
and understanding how the work we do can
be done different or better leveraging
Advanced methods
I use it most frequently
when I am thinking through New
Challenges things that aren't in flight
and I think through
how could I apply my learnings to this
without going through a traditional
development background without going all
the way back to the source and trying to
get some key information or a key
attribute from that source to determine
the specific transaction can I can I
ascertain that transaction based on
methods based on mobility of or mobility
of the of the transaction there's
there's other methods to use and it
opens the door to those
wonderful
John thank you so much for sharing your
experiences and how and why you joined
us on this journey I'm really proud to
have you as one of our graduates out of
the Purdue program and I'm glad you
found it valuable as well I'm taking a
few takeaways out of this conversation
as well one is there is no stopping
learning you talk about being a lifelong
learner
and I think that's a big takeaway for
anybody who's watching this video Don't
Stop learning or you become Obsolete and
that's a key takeaway from your
experience the second thing that you
mentioned was being able to practice
those skills Hands-On being able to
apply them in your job at some level is
going to be really critical in any
program that really gets you life skills
and the last part is being really
structured about it and having you know
virtual Labs being able to actually
practice these you know skills as you're
going through them is really critical
John I want to thank you very very much
for your time with us today and I hope
you come back for the next program there
is another Advanced AI program which I
think at some level might be the next
step in that Journey so hopefully we'll
see you uh back here sometime all right
thank you very much and I appreciate the
time
foreign